one girl threatened two girl one girl
basically threatened like the Indian
like Mafia or some [__] or like some
Muslim she she was like in some Indian
or Muslim Community and like
she just threatened to like bring these
people that she knew to kill me and the
other one um threatened to bring her
brothers to beat me up and I was just
like honestly like I'm just being real
honestly if you guys kill me like if
they're gonna kill me or beat me up like
I can't really stop you but what I'm not
gonna do is Bend to your will because
you're trying to like Bully me I'm not
gonna do that so you can bully me you
can threaten me but if I do it for you
then people will get word that they can
just do that and get [__] taken down